the great ones always return Jesus
MacArthur jay-z hey America did you miss
my hot breath in your ear in the 70s
they were an elite unit where did you
get those clothes at the toilet store
they've done studies you know 60% of the
time it works every time they rose like
the Phoenix and then which the guy who
lost his job to his wife I'm Veronica
coins they were gone we're starting a
24-hour news channel and we want you
this is feels right the news team is
back they came to reclaim the glory they
once knew staring Jesco it's called the
Goodwood Revival get a taste which is
coincidentally the name with a pill I
take to stay Barrow between the sheets
to do the thing that God put Ron
Burgundy on this earth to do have
salon-quality hair and read the news
welcome the enn global news network
Wow right on the lens I'm sorry sweetie
you're the best quickest hmm he's not
that great
what'd he say he said you're not that
great
like the parts of your face that are
covered skin bring on the fun bags
someone put the story in all capital
letters and I I thought I was supposed
to yell it
tonight's top story is cracked we feel
that right away it's just refreshing
we just done wit and brought it you
can't handle it little mama oh no oh boy
that escalated quickly I mean that
really got out of hand fast